the united states declaration of
independence reads we hold these truths
to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
that they are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights
that sounds great
but who does it apply to and what are
those rights
that's what we are going to discuss in
the few in these lessons we're going to
think about what rights do you have as
an individual and what rights might you
give up to the state
we'll talk about the history of civil
rights and civil liberties in the united
states even though we have these very
powerful and very high-minded words in
the declaration of independence in 1776
not all men and especially not all women
had these types of rights as the nation
was founded in the 1780s and 1790s
how did that evolve and how will that
story continue to evolve as the united
states tries to become a more perfect
union in these lessons
we're going to make sure we understand
the difference between say a civil
liberty and a civil right we're also
going to learn a lot about the bill of
rights and what liberties and rights
they protect and finally we're going to
learn how people have organized
throughout american history to make
change and to ensure that as a nation we
are as just of a nation as possible and
so whether your concern is
what rights do i have if i get arrested
to how do i make sure that i live in a
just society these lessons are going to
be interesting for you so i'm excited
about going on this journey with you and
if you want to learn more and get deep
practice with immediate feedback i
encourage you to look at these lessons
on khan academy.org